tous
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir de voir des gens vivants
et parce que c'est vrai l'intelligence
artificielle c'est aussi un peu ça c'est
qu'on se prend une quantité
d'informations incroyable dans les dents
et et parfois on oublie un peu de pensée
de penser à l'instant présent et on
oublie que pendant qu'on passe des
heures à étudier des choses qui sont
robotique il se passe des choses dans le
monde aussi et chaque minute vous avez
déjà réfléchi vous à tout ce qui se
passe en une minute dans le monde
eh ben ça sera le prochain sujet de tedx
fribourg vous avez deux heures
[Musique]
toutes les minutes
dans le doute il faire ce fan oiseaux
tombent un feu c'est à une maison pour
un arbre arrête de grandir une rivière
filles par sécher ainsi elle commence à
s'endormir une étoile décide de très
vite repris minutes dans le monde
dix-huit personnes meurent de faim 900
millions se serre la main on attend un
bus un taxi un chauffeur ou bien train
on ne fait pas aujourd'hui les choses
qu'on pourra faire demain toutes les
minutes
dans le monde neuf personnes attrapent
le sida la terre tremble au moins cinq
fois 500 femmes de belle-maman suite à
l'orgasme du jour d'avant souvenirs
soyeux ou accident violeur ou bien avant
toutes les minutes
dans le monde 150 millions d'e-mails
sont envoyés dans le ciel qui croise le
chemin virtuel facto remplacé par
courrier en papier et stylo bille
devancé par clavier souris tous plus
mignons dans le monde ça accuse
s'emprisonne sa complice à fait licite
ça dénonce ça pardonne ça recommence
assassine ça aime trop ça ment ça cache
maladroitement sa mère sa renault sa
calcul ça disparaisse à pronostics sali
sa critique ça avoli s'attend que ça va
si ça ferraille sarraut fille ça gagne
ça manipule sa cuisine ou bien ça lit ça
donne des conseils
ça prend des cuites çà roses des jardins
sa braquent des banques
ça roule trop vite ça court pour prendre
la fuite ça évite les banques ça coûte
les gens qui manquent toutes les minutes
dans l'it quelqu'un dit que c'était
mieux avant autant du droit et des
bouffons
ministre dans les bleus au les nudistes
remettre le pas les poissons rouges
boivent de l'eau les politiciens
boufleur doit on se regarde dans un
miroir pendant des heures de base en
haut on s'attarde sur nos rides nos
cicatrices nos défauts en bombe le torse
en cogles d'eau et on retourne compter
nos sous pour payer nos impôts
roddick la terre va mal qu'elle
ressemble à un carnaval que les idiots
sont au pouvoir
alors c'est clair il n'y a plus d'espoir
que tu as voulu flow côte de preuves ou
la dèche que sarko est une et
que ça me fait une pimbêche pour dick
l'homme devient gaga comme si c'était
une race à part que l'être humain est
dangereux vicieux barbare que le sol
grouille de mauvaises herbes de serpents
et de cafards et que la planète regorge
de vilain petit canard
et le plus drôle dans tout ça c'est
qu'on nous demande de nous aimer on nous
arrange lisation les autres et on nous
dit cohabiter il ya des cons qui nous
observe comme des souris de laboratoire
pour accoucher d'un thème gnostique qui
divisera les blancs des noirs on
travaille pour vivre et puis on vit pour
dépenser l'argent qu'on n'a pas encore
gagné mais qu'on nous a grassement loué
six cateau servez vous vous rembourserai
quand vous pourrez depuis si vous crever
avant vos enfants seront là pour payer
et même les fleurs préférées c'est la
tête en bas elle préfère être admirée
par tous ces gens qui ne sont plus là
parce qu'ils sont partis avant ceux qui
sont partis à temps parce qu'ils se
marre en nous regardant morflé comme des
gros débutants
c'est pas glorieux mais c'est comme ça
on prend pas toujours les bonnes
décisions et on fait pas toujours les
bons choix
on ferme les yeux on tend les bras et en
avance à l'aveuglette sous les ordres de
nos hommes de loi sans écouter notre
propre planète
et puis on s'étonne recevant des coups
de poing dans le temps quand on
pleurniche pour une broutille comme un
enfant gâté
lorsqu'on se plaint d'une journée
minable devant les horreurs du jt ou
consommant faut pour un simple repas
raté on oublie qu'à l'âge du fer y avait
pas de like i need follower qu'il
mangeait à même le sol et qu'ils
s'aimaient à même le coeur qu'il vivait
au jour le jour parce que nos futurs
n'existait pas et qu'il croyait que mère
nature parce qu'il n'y avait ni dieu ni
croix aujourd'hui on ne sait pas encore
où on va mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
y va d'un pas sûr d'en valant d'abord
timides ou sans cela on se regarde comme
des lions en cage en miaulant comme des
bébés chats on sent la moutarde nous
arriver au tard mais on perd nos temps
froid on devrait réaliser que pour se
sortir de toute cette merde on a besoin
de pas grand chose
il nous faudrait juste 2018 en lucidité
et 30 secondes de courage que qu'ils
tombent aux grands sa gueule et qu'il
pressent sur le bouton pause en
balançant
en coupe vous êtes mauvais allez on
commence le tournage
[Applaudissements]
esca des suisses allemands dans la salle
je suis désolé la prochaine fois je vous
l'a refait dans votre langue mais pour
le moment je ne suis pas encore parfaite
dans le domaine
[Musique]
oh
oooh
où
oh oh oh
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y avait des miettes sur le canapé
une cigarette écrasé dans les fonds d'un
cendrier quelques verres de tequila en
vain c'est sur le parquet une liste
d'idées noires jeté par terre et
chiffonné avesnes et reste pour l'heure
du dîner
une belle assiette emballé dans du
papier d'alu doré avec ton odeur qui
débordé sur les côtés la bouffe était
vivante connector a pas oubliés avec des
cheveux dans le lavabo de brosses à
dents en lacets d'un dentifrice saveurs
comprend quelques bouteilles de parfum
ali comme des dominos une lettre écrite
à la main avec des insultes au verso y
avait trop d'eau dans le gaz est pas
passé dans le 27 et écrit en majuscules
tu n'es pas tout je ne suis pas rien les
moments tomber dans mon corps j'ai le
coeur qui perd la tête et mes pensées
qui se déchire comme un ciel zébré de
comètes
en
[Musique]
bon
des traces dans la cheminée
et les cendres d'une histoire qui
étaient partis en fumée une boîte fermée
à clé était déposé dans le feu sur le
couvercle c'était grave et le plus beau
souvenir à 2 y'avait des larmes sur un
oreiller
et des rêves collé au plafond par
centaines et parmi les rancoeurs d'un
hameau blessés les reproches pas digéré
qui reste suscité dans le noir
une fois la nuit tombée avec
dans les mots rooney qui faisait danser
les feuilles dorées par la fin de l'été
pendant que l'étape étant mais rejeté
les vagues sur les rochers et que les
poumons de son coeur buvait la tasse à
sa santé
coudon
[Musique]
cav est décrit dans un compte entrer
des pas perdus ni coups manqués les
valises pleines à craquer les rangs de
vignes portes claquer un dernier cadeau
lancé enroulé dans du sata à déballer
dans l'escalier gavin pâques dans une
fleur séchée
et sur chaque pétale replier au crayon
noir c'était noté même si parfois le
temps aux fans les ive et reprise par
passé devient l'étincelle de maffle en
veux-tu bien m'épouser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un truc ou où on sent que
c'est un truc qui vous pas super bien
d'ailleurs ça se voit l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur et est donc je dirais que je
me sens vraiment c'est pas un mal être
absolue mais c'est vraiment
[Musique]
bonjour docteur j'vais pas très bien
j'ai besoin de vos remèdes et ça peut
pas attendre demain
j'ai mal au coeur je me vois plus les
mains je me tord de douleur je crève
c'est certain regardez le blanc des yeux
il est comme un c nuageux on dirait que
sur chaque pot bien j'étais champignons
vénéneux
le soir quand je m'endors je dois
laisser la lumière car dans le nord
retarde pas tort s'amuser avec son laser
il m'a dit c'est normal mais m
il m'a dit oui c'est alors garder ma
gorge digère même plus les bonnes
nouvelles qu'elle soit salée ou sucrée
j'ai comme une pelote de ficelles à
attacher à mme atrache et j'ai l'estomac
dans les talons
je dois prendre mes jambes à mon goût
pour ne pas mettre les pieds dans le
plat corps et âme à tour de bras je joue
des coudes 1 contre coeur pour déjouer
ma dernière heure et je me fais des
cheveux blancs elle pourrait y dent pour
dent et m'a dit il m'a dit oui alors
touché mes veines là elle songe les tons
bleus n'y a plus rien qui coule de temps
ils sont attachés de bordeaux je me fais
un sang d'encre qui nourrit même plus
mes stylos mes globules rouges sont
aussi pâle que le rose de mon cerveau et
quand je sors dans la rue je vois plus
mon reflet dans les vitrines
j'ai les fesses qui se dégonfle et ça
qu'ils se ratatine parce que les deux se
déplace comme une carcasse de limaces en
plus j'ai mal aux pieds gravier dans mes
godasses
il m'a dit il m'a dit
[Musique]
ok
mais aux fins docteur jouait pas en
conflit ou une fleur shivek je débarque
à l'improviste et que ça fait pas trop
votre bonheur regardez moi voyez ma
gueule avouez ça fait peur s'il vous
plaît sauvez moi ou bien je meurs
pouvait pas blessé comme ça pouvait pas
laisser crever comme une bête à l'agonie
devant la porte de votre entrée 8 mai en
nature en cash en bakchich
je vous mettrai sur le podium de mes
personnages fétiches il m'a dit c'est
normal mais dès que je puisse vous aider
je suis pas toubib du cantonnier je lui
rapporter les pentes au fait que je
devais lui réparer malaisie vous attend
notre dernier bureau du fonds il vous
entends tu arrive essoufflé paper niche
et il m'a confié que ce n'est pas facile
le médecin des imbéciles alors que pour
les calmer et commencer par un doigt
dans le nombre et le bon courage pour
courage pour courage courage vous
courage
[Musique]
pourquoi
bonjour docteur j'vais pas de rien j'ai
besoin de vous remettre des saints peut
pas attendre demain
j'ai mal au coeur je vois puis les mains
j'ai me tord de douleur je crève certain
regard des vents de monsieur qui comme
ainsi nuageux on dirait que sur chaque
pot pierre j'étais champignons vénéneux
le soir quand je vois ma bière je le
dois laisser la lumière car dans le noir
je vois pas jour quand je dois viser mon
verre il m'a dit c'est pas normal et il
m'a dit oh c'est pas banal
il m'a dit vous devez avoir mal
il m'a dit
et fait demi tour
toshi rectal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]